il est là il est arrivé il est beau il
est chaud il est juste largue abc le
nouveau macbook air avec la nouvelle
puce f2 d'apple il est arrivé dans ce
carton le carton était dans un colis et
le colis est dans les mains de livreurs
jusque là on a une jolie histoire ça
c'est cool et ça c'est chouette pourquoi
et bien parce que c'est une évolution
par rapport au macbook air est moins con
à coolus l'équateur en 2020 se croire
déjà ça passe très très vite il y en a
eu d'autres qui sont arrivés par la
suite du macbook pro on a déjà parlé
c'est chouette c'est intéressant et
pourquoi ce macbook air est intéressant
et bien parce que c'est une évolution et
surtout ce qui est vraiment intéressant
arrière si vous voulez c'est
l'émancipation niveau des puces on l'a
déjà vu en 2020 apple s'est émancipé de
intel et de ses puces pour arriver que
ces puces maisons et des puces maisons
qui sont tellement performante qui
marche tellement bien quand on a vu
arriver la puce allemand n'a fait genre
ouais ok sur le patriotisme a fait genre
oh oh oh wow est là avec la puce m2 ça
continue alors il n'y a pas une énorme
évolution par rapport à l'allemagne
avait tellement une très grosse
différence entre les puces intel et la
m1 qui était monstrueux que entre la m1
et la m 2 on va un peu plus loin hors
continue l'histoire sans bien
révolutionner l'histoire mais c'est
chouette c'est cool c'est une machine
qui évolue légèrement qui continuent
tout doucement son histoire qui continue
il n'y a pas de grosse révolution mais
qui avance dans le temps donc on va
faire le tour complet de ce macbook air
de 2022 avec la puce m2 on va regarder
quelles sont les nouveautés on va
essayer de voir s'il est intéressant est
ce qu'il est fait pour vous et tout ça
ça fait beaucoup à raconter et on y va
quand ben maintenant tout de suite
bookmark bim paf
alors la boîte je vous montrais
rapidement si vous êtes boiteau fils
pense pas que ça existe les boîtes au
fil c'est des boîtes très simple l'ordi
vous avez votre chargeur les petites
infos là c'est tout ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur pas de superflu on n'en fait
pas des caisses est très simple merci
apple comme ça au moins on s'embête pas
on passe la boîte derrière ça ça
m'intéresse parce que c'est justement ce
macbook air n 2 qui vient d'arriver que
d'être annoncé que fin et très léger
quoi kg 23 1 kg 24 portes extrêmement
précis je trouve très calme très jolie
alors comme on est sur du macbook air on
les sort des connectiques extrêmement
lite vous avez une prise jack ici tout
simplement de l'autre côté vous n'avez
pas grand chose vous avez de la charge
en accès y fait ça c'est cool d'avoir du
magsafe c'est un truc qui a été
rondement des comme ça vous prenez si
jamais ça tire ça l'on lève ya pas de
problème vous avez deux prises ici en
usb c'est thunderball 4 et c'est tout
pas plus pas moins a alors après autre
petite particularité puisque je vous le
dis tout de suite il ya un bloc de
charges suis là regardez les voir mettre
ko hop là c'est le 35 watts il est livré
que la carte graphique avec des choeurs
le gpu à 10 coeurs si vous prenez
l'option avec le gpu à 8 heures vous
aurez un bloc de charge 30 watts il ya
une différence il faut le savoir sur le
35 watts vous avez deux prises usb c'est
comme ça si vous voulez venir brancher
un iphone à côté ou alors une apeloig
tout ce que vous voulez vous pouvez
faire tout ça vraiment pas mal autre
troupe qui est très cool c'est que le
cordon et bien sûr cette espèce de petit
mil ont juste pas qu'on passe sur ce
très long mais ça va être très très
sérieux comme ça c'est bien c'est joli
en plus c'est totalement a sorti avec
cette nouvelle couleur qui s'appelle la
mine night minuit c'est très élégant on
retrouve le blanc du bloc de charge on
retrouve le côté sombre un peu noir du
midnight je trouve ça hyper classe et ça
c'est chouette dites moi si vous aimez
cette course et toutes nouvelles
couleurs un qui vient d'arriver en 2022
uniquement vous le trouvez bien sûr ce
macbook air en tout cas comment vous la
trouvez elle vous plaît vous plaît pas
qu'est ce que vous pensez du design avec
cette grosse pomme au centre moi je
prends ça très cool alors je vous le dis
tout de suite parce qu'il ya plein de
personnes qui me diront ok t'es bien
mignon bon vu sucre ont été bien mignon
apple 2 ports usb cc largement par
suffisant et c'est très clair et on l'a
vu notamment avec le macbook pro qui a
été sorti je les jetais côté qu'elle
l'année dernière ils ont raflé les
connectiques ils ont rajouté un lecteur
de cartes sd c'est sûr que quand on veut
une machine professionnelle il faut plus
de porc et ils l'ont fait il donc on
risqué parce qu'avant on avait
uniquement quatre ports usb c'est donc
ça c'est cool mais sur un macbook air
c'est un ordinateur plus de bureautique
plus plus plus plus on peut faire plein
de choses avec ils vont pas aussi loin
ce que je vous conseille de venir
acheter c'est un petit est bon c'est pas
un pub d'apple je sais plus où est ce
que je l'achetais mais c'est un petit up
qui est très cool qui vous permet de
venir avoir de l'usbc du hdmi lecteur de
cartes sd prise jack mène du vga un
autre usb c'est là un rj45 donc ce genre
de petits up c'est un truc avoir tout le
temps avec soi si on est créateur parce
que vous êtes sûr qu'avec ça vous ne
tomberez jamais en rade au niveau des
collectifs ou sept jours tranquilles
pour ça je vous recommande plus plus
plus plus plus puisque cette machine
n'est pas pourvu de plein de portes
cette machine avait pour but de ce sont
très très très sympa déjà elle reprend
le design je vous montre là du dernier
macbook pro avec cette petite encoche
petite encoche qui est intéressante et
surtout ce qui a été améliorée ici est
bien c'est que vous avez une webcam avec
une plus haute qualité donc ça c'est
cool je vous montrais c'est du 1080p on
augmente la qualité on augmente la
résolution on n'est plus uniquement en
720p ce qui fait que c'est quand même
vachement bien pour toutes les personnes
qui vont vouloir mieux travailler au
niveau du télétravail tout ce qui va
être travail à distance qu'il va être
conférence il ya de plus en plus
j'espère de moins en moins dans les
temps à venir mais pour l'instant rien
n'est encore un petit peu donc ça c'est
bien il y avait déjà fait que le macbook
pro et le fant et macbook air tant mieux
et c'est une bonne chose autre truc très
intéressant c'est le magic qui bordent
combien retrouvé l'allant de magic qui
bordent il est très bien fichu
l'attention ce que je vais trouver
d'intéressant effectivement décès votre
petite taille d'ici pour venir
déverrouiller capteur d'empreintes
digitales ça sécurise aussi extrêmement
intéressant et c'est sécurisant
également convenir faire vos achats avec
apple paye vous posez votre doigt vous
payer en ligne vous êtes tranquille donc
ça c'est chouette autre truc très
chouette que fait très très bien apple
eh bien c'est ce très grand trackpad qui
maîtrise très bien une fois de plus sur
design ils n'arrivent pas partout mais
on est quasiment au niveau du bord donc
il est grand il est hyper confortable
très sympa à venir utiliser donc ça
c'est pareil c'est un super outil autres
trucs à bien savoir c'est qu'à la
différence d'un macbook pro à bien vous
n'avez pas de haut parleurs sylla sur le
côté tout se trouve intégrée directement
alors et c'est là justement où
l'histoire est chouette
autre vie numérique regardez je montre
en main eagles s'envolent un peu plus
grands comptes c'est la partie musicale
ils sont hyper fort chez apple alors le
son il y aura un peu moins deux côtés
grave qu'on va pouvoir retrouver dans le
macbook pro mais pour autant il ya un
son qui se passe ya lisez et c'est une
des nouveautés qu'on a ici sur cette
version 2022 par rapport à la version de
2020 on à l'audio spatiale et c'est vrai
que pour autant vous regardez il n'y a
pas d'eau parlera en façade mais le son
devient là et le son via un peu des
côtés ce qui fait qu'ils à côté qui est
plus immersif lorsque vous venez écouter
du contenu et ça une fois de plus un
tour de force et c'est une vraie belle
maîtrise de la part d'apple que vous
pouvez y aller regarder alors le son est
assez médium ça manque un peu de rondeur
mais bon on a pas tout avoir non plus il
ya plein d'ordi ou lorsque vous faites
ça vous avez des petits haut parleurs
qui font un peu coincoin en façade et
sait pas où on l'a alors ça est médium
une fois de plus c'est pas très large au
niveau du spectre qui nous montrent
grave derrière ron davantage mais pour
autant c'est vraiment spécialisés
regardez j'ai l'impression que le son il
vient peu à droite de gauche et ils sont
hyper balès pour ça et ibos vachement
bien donc ça c'est un point fort si vous
voulez augmenter l'expérience soit vous
venez vous brancher directement avec une
petite prise jack sur le côté et là
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal fichue
si le point se fait ce sera encore mieux
donc là c'est plutôt cool sinon vous
avez dû me to 5.0 pour venir à péret un
casque arpels maxou dr paul ce que vous
voulez bref vous pouvez bien le faire
donc ça aussi c'est vachement chouette
donc l'expérience multimédia les très
bonnes d'autant plus que là vous avez
une diagonale qui va être légèrement
plus grande dit bien légèrement avant
c'était du 13,3 pouces on est sur du 13
6 pouces sait pas grand-chose la
différence attention c'est qu'on n'est
pas son truc révolutionnaire après le
tout qu'y vraiment pour coup
révolutionnaire c'est la petite encoche
lâchez pas si elle vous dérangerait ce
que vous aviez déjà sur le macbook pro
les nerfs parce que vous n'ayez pas moi
je trouve ça pas mal au début ce
tailleur rouge suis pas convaincu et
puis on s'y habitue et puis ça me
dérange pas parce que en fait c'est
toujours une barre informative en haut
vous allez retrouver ça vient pas trop
manger votre contenu et même lorsque je
me mets en plein écran sur une vidéo
youtube regardez et bien c'est pas grave
puisque les contenus sont souvent
allongé en 16/9 des fois en 21 9ème donc
pas de souci ça ne pose pas de problème
donc ça fonctionne alors après c'est un
liquid retina display vous avez un ami
un de couleur c'est une gamme de
couleurs p3 vous avez un écran qui va
jusqu'à 500 litres résolution full hd +
2560 par 1600 64 pixels 224 pixels par
pouce bon ben vous lirez la fiche
technique aussi bien que moi sur le site
d'apple mais le truc qui nous intéresse
c'est ce qui est à l'intérieur et malgré
la finesse et c'est là où ils sont
balèzes au niveau des finesses de
gravure parce qu'on est quand même sur
du 5 nanomètres ici c'est plutôt bien je
sais pas qui l'aggravent par contre en
cette puce est vrai qu'on a pas eu
l'info du côté de chez apple s du tsl ne
sait ou pas je ne sais pas qui va
aggraver sa toujours est il que cette
puce n 2 elle permet d'aller un peu plus
loin je dis bien un peu plus loin que la
puce allemand alors je vous donne les
specs d'apple j'ai pas fais des mesures
précises ce qu'ils nous donnent eux
c'est assez intéressant en termes de
chiffres ils nous disent que sur
photoshop par rapport à la m1 vous allez
1,2 fois plus vite un peu plus vite par
contre par rapport à la version
précédente avec un i5 intel vous allez
cinq fois plus vite face et photoshop
sur final cut final cut pro c'est mon
logiciel de montage on va 1,4 fois plus
vite et on va 15 fois plus vite par
rapport à intel autant vous dire que sa
tartine un axe est sûre premiere pro on
va 1,6 fois plus vite vers su cette fois
plus vite sur un i5 ça c'est intéressant
parce que voyez final cut pro sen
logiciel apple a très clairement dit et
par apple on voit qu'on va 1,4 fois plus
vite par rapport à la m1 mais quinze
fois plus vite par rapport à la s5 c'est
monstrueux mais premiere pro n'est pas
du tout un logiciel apple qui est un
logiciel hadopi on va 1,6 fois plus vite
par rapport à l'iphone donc on va un peu
plus vite on va un peu moins vite que
les intel fois cette je pense que c'est
parce que final cut pro comme c'est un
logiciel apple édité par apple ils ont
dû faire des modifications qui vont
l'optimiser par rapport à intel versus
premiere pro qui a réussi à l'hadopi à
mon avis un truc un peu là dedans au
niveau de deux ce qui se passe donc
voyez on va quand même qu'on va un peu
plus vite par rapport à la main si vous
avez un mac book air de 2020 et que vous
vous posez la question de venir changer
je ne pense pas qu'il faille venir
changer si par contre vous avez un
macbook air ou un macbook pro dean tel
est que ce format là vous convient de là
ça va vraiment faire changer votre vie
ça va révolutionner mais si vous avez
une puce soit un macbook pro en m1 et
l'impro à me max et compagnie ou alors
que vous avez un macbook air avec un
aimant ne changez pas l'ordinateur est
très récent conviendra très bien vous
pourrez incarner dans le temps mais
celui là il faut vraiment aller dessus
si vous avez une machine qui est
vraiment antérieures ou si vous venez
d'un pc et que ça vous fait de l'oeil
parce que vous aurez une très jolie
machine à grosse différence qu'on va
avoir par rapport à un macbook pro en
rien les connectiques et compagnie a
fort mal évidemment bien qu'on ait quand
même macbook pro 13 pouces mais la vraie
grosse différence c'est qu'avec le pro
aura toujours plus être très belle ce
que je dis mais c'est la vérité
notamment au niveau du traitement multi
fichiers au niveau du traitement je sais
pas si vous faites de la vidéo avec
beaucoup de sources 4k vous irait
beaucoup plus loin qu'un macbook pro en
termes de puissance au niveau graphique
vous irait beaucoup plus loin avec son
ordinateur là je vais pouvoir faire du
montage vidéo sans problème vous allez
pouvoir me mettre en place des fichiers
4k multi fichiers manamia bref ça y
arrivera un moment dans vos projets vous
irait plus loin avec les macbook pro
donc il faut vraiment venir se poser la
question aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
avez besoin de faire quels sont vos
usages est ce que c'est de la
bureautique un peu coup lui auquel cas
si vous êtes vraiment tranquille si vous
voulez faire du code vous êtes
tranquille vous allez ce qu'il faut ça
dépend de la taille de vos projets ça
dépend de vos ambitions ça dépend d'où
vous en êtes aujourd'hui en 2022 versus
ou vous en serez en 2024 2025 2026 est
ce que vous pensez vous avez besoin
d'énormément de performance peut être
séparée de ce qu'il faut et peut-être
sur un macbook pro ou alors est-ce que
ce que vous avez la performance vous
suffira et vous allez restant des
projets à peu près dans des tailles
dimensionné pour cette machine c'est
vraiment ce qu'il faut venir se demander
parce que moi je trouve très très cool
cette machine et si on a besoin de faire
un peu de montage de temps en temps
qu'on veut faire quelques projets mais
qu'on veut pas non plus bourrine et vous
pouvez y aller là dessus sans aucun
problème autre truc qui est intéressant
à la différence d'un macbook pro c'est
qu'ici vous n'avez pas de ventilateur
alors le refroidissement se fera bien
évidemment mais c'est une machine qui
est très silencieuse donc si vous voulez
du silence de la quiétude et pouvoir
aborder les projets un peu couru
derrière on est tranquille ici et tout
en sachant qu'ils aussi nouveauté par
rapport à la génération d'avant là vous
pouvez avoir soyons vigilants drame soit
16 giga de ram ça vous l'aviez déjà
avant et là on peut monter jusqu'à 24
giga de ram alp ddr5 le stockage c'est
la même chose 256 512 un terrain ou de
terrain l'autonomie alors apple nous
allons jusqu'à 18 heures d'autonomie en
venant regarder des vidéos si vous
regardez pendant 18 heures vous allez
avoir des yeux un peu comme un lapin
caraquet myxomatose et jusqu'à 15 heures
en navigation sur le web ce qui est sûr
est ce qu'il marchait déjà très bien
avec la puce à main c'est qu'on a une
excellente autonomie elle est préservée
ici vous aurez la même autonomie que la
puce n en ont pas mieux pas moins pire
la même chose tout en sachant qu'ici on
est compatible bloc de chasse 67 soit
vous avez soit du 30 wassoulou 35 watts
en fonction du gp vous allez prendre
dans les options je vous invite à aller
jeter un coup d'oeil sur le site d'apple
ou sur des revendeurs des larges comme
un lien en bas dans la description mais
si vous voulez le recharger à 50% trois
minutes il faut passer par un blog
charge soixante sept mois à venir
acheter en supplément après si vous
n'avez pas besoin d'aller aussi vite
cette autonomie cab relativement bonne
et que vous avez le temps pour bien vous
organiser pour recharger vous avez soit
du 30 watts du 35 watts il faut le
savoir je vais pas vous faire un laufon
de vous parler de l'ouest parce qu'on
est sur un mac os montérégie on aura
toutes les mises à jour qui vont arriver
dans les années suivantes bien
évidemment ici on a du wifi 6 quand même
la génération précédente et après ce qui
nous intéressait c les tarifs alors
regardez au livre boum on commence pour
vous refaire très très rapidement au
niveau cpu vous avez lu liqueur quoi
qu'il se passe au niveau et paix vous
avez soit 8 soit 10 coeur d'une
différence de tarifs ici je vous lis que
ça inclut aussi une différence au niveau
du du bloc de charge et vous avez ces
scores au niveau du nord alan joyce la
différence si vous voulez c'est que je
fais très très rapidement parce que ça
s'est imposé sur le site d'apple avec
huit coeurs cpu siècle am2 vous allez
avoir 18% de perf en plus par rapport à
la génération précédente par rapport au
macbook air en main avec le dycker gpu
pas le 8 heures le dycker gpu vous avez
35 % de performances graphiques en plus
ça c'est intéressant et au niveau du
north island jeunes vous avez 40 % de
performances en plus par rapport à la
génération précédente alors le tarif sur
la version avec le gpu à 8h et 256 go de
stockage vous êtes à
1499 euros et sur la version gpu avec
dycker et 512 giga de stockage vous êtes
à
1849 euros ça commence à faire un petit
tarif canck et qui a ses hauts et puis
après ça va dépendre si vous voulez
différentes options ou pas je vais vous
montrer sur le site d'apple alors
regarder si on se met là par exemple et
qu'on va jeter un coup d'oeil sur le
site d'apple avec la puce m2 ok je veux
celui là je me dis que je veux le dic
heure par exemple il me plaît bien il
fait de l'oeil ok je le sélectionne vos
îles tarifs 1849 euros et puis après
vous venez un peu personnalisé
l'histoire vous voyez vous êtes en 8
gigas de ram si vous voulez monter en
fait ce giga de ram et bien vous
rajoutez 230 euros si vous avez monté en
24 gigaba ou 230 euros c'est jade à 2300
euros et après le stockage ça dépend si
vous monter jusqu'à 2 terrain vous êtes
sur une config à 3000 euros donc tout de
suite les tarifs s'envolent alors après
à vous de voir si vous avez besoin de ça
ou si vous voulez juste faire du
stockage auquel cas prenez un disque dur
externe pour ça vous coûtera quand même
un peu moins cher et puis après si vous
voulez monter avec le 67 soit noyé up
inclus en tête qu'ils incluent parce que
là on est très cher mais ce qui les
inclut si je me mets par exemple j'en
sais rien on va pas dessus avril inclus
aussi donc c'est soit l'adaptateur
double ok là ok bon ben ça me va bien
tout ça pas mal le clavier alors après
les logiciels en plus que peut venir
choisir qui nous ça ça marche donc ça
c'est cette version là ici je prends
l'autre version avec le 8 heures au
niveau du gpu je vous montre le tarif de
base dont je vous disais à 1499 euros
fait voir c'est la même chose là si je
veux à nous regarder la voyez par
exemple là si je veux monter avec le 35
watts et plus 20 balles le 67 watts et
plus 20 balles s'emparer pas des
collants très honnêtement ça je pensais
que celle beaucoup plus cher tout en
sachant qu'ici vous avez et vous le
montrer tout à leur double sortie pour
venir se recharger facilement que c'est
plutôt pas mal aussi donc la voyez c'est
de la même manière là je me dis que
alors après je switche directement là
mais si je reste sur mon 8h au niveau du
cpu et 8 heures au niveau de mon gpu et
que je veux me booster ma mémoire par
exemple avec un 16 giga parce que je
veux que ce soit un peu plus je vous
conseille un très honnêtement 16 dans ce
huit quand même leur minimum et que vous
voulez un peu de stockage en 512 et bien
déjà voyez on est quasiment à 2000 euros
tout de suite ça certains prix et tarifs
s'envolent donc ça c'est quand même
comme ça que ça se passe chez apple il
faut savoir si vous en voulez un peu
plus ça va coûter un peu plus cher moi
je vous recommande sur cette machine la
très honnêtement devenir m au moins 16
giga de ram parce que si vous voulez
faire un peu de vidéo 8 gigas de ram ça
sera largement pas suffisant si vous
voulez faire uniquement un peu de
bureautique bricoler aller sur le web
regarder des films des séries ex
combattantes bureautique hockey 8 gigas
de ram samba mais si je commence à faire
de la vidéo gelé minimum 16 giga de ram
à l'intérieur et si je peux mettre un
petit 24 là je veux faire plaisir mais
là je sens la version avec 10 coeurs au
niveau du gpu donc ça dépend de vous ça
dépend de vos usages voyez moi je me
suis amusé par exemple un petit
lightroom ça marche vachement bien je
peux venir faire des multi tâches tous
les côtés ça réagit très très rapidement
je suis de l'autre côté sur photoshop je
peux bien me marrer j'ai pas de souci je
peux bien me faire du montage vidéo ici
aussi également pas de souci ça marche
donc il n'y a pas de problème de ce côté
là maintenant il faut savoir vous ce que
vous voulez en faire quels sont vos
usages quels sont vos besoins je vous le
dis bureautique 8 gigas de ram on a
besoin d'un peu plus d convenir faire de
la vidéo qu'on vient faire un peu de
multi canal avec des projets un peu plus
lourd sur photoshop on pas passer sur du
16 giga de ram ça augmente le tarif je
vous recommande quand même 512 jia de
stockage 256 on peut mais par contre
vous avez souvent venir dégager des
projets vous embêter 512 ya de stockage
de tarifs montent un peu mais la machine
est sympa d'os cet ordinateur il faut
aller dessus pour moi aller dessus sans
aucun problème les yeux fermés si vous
arrivez d'un pc ou si vous arrivez d'un
acte version intel si vous avez déjà un
mac 2020 avec je dirais un m1 et mme
prono max ça ira ne changez pas garder
encore votre machine un petit peu voilà
ce que j'ai à vous dire cette machine je
trouve bien ça évolue il ya une nouvelle
couleur on muscle un petit peu la
machine on propose des alternatives des
choses un peu différentes une webcam
avec une meilleure résolution mais dans
l'idée on révolutionne pas complètement
l'histoire mais on évolue petit à petit
année par année on continue on reste à
jour bois de nouvelles techno et ça
c'est cool donc si elle vous intéresse
je vous donne un lien juste en bas dans
la description et puis à vous de me dire
ce que vous en pensez ce que vous avez
déjà un macbook air avec aimants est ce
que vous pourriez y aller ce que vous
n'y êtes pas aller si oui pour quelles
raisons alors après il y avait un truc
qui fasse vraiment savoir c'est que en
2020 lorsque et main est arrivé il y
avait plein de software qui n'était pas
encore compatibles et moi j'ai attendu
avant de passer sur mon macbook pro avec
le n 1 pro je suis restée sous le intel
pendant quelques temps pourquoi j'avais
les deux machines parce que j'avais mon
logiciel de colorimétrie qui n'était pas
compatible avec le m1 aujourd'hui il est
donc voyez aujourd'hui on peut y aller
un peu plus sereinement qu'en 2020 le
calme deux ans après donc je pense que
si vous n'avez pas encore de macbook air
ou de macbook pro avec un m1 ou avec un
m2 vous pouvez y aller même le m en
reste très très bon au niveau du macbook
air pouvait gagner sans problème voilà
un peu mon ressenti et mon retour à vous
donner aujourd'hui j'espère que ça vous
aura un test j'ai pas que ça vous aura
plu prenez soin de vous en continu par
les tec je vous embrasse gros bisous et
puis de l'amour beaucoup d'amour que de
l'amour de la mort
m
utah